don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
brother Brock is someone that is known a
Turkish influencer who is known for
cooking and his beautiful smile mellow
Sparrow Tyler preserve him and he does
many many amazing works alhamdulillah we
know his videos from even though I don't
really follow it that much but here and
there we know his videos with a big
smile that lightens everybody's face and
we know the prophet peace be upon him
said smile indeed it is Sunnah it's a
form of Charity and alhamdulillah when
you watch his videos someone smiling
gives you positivity you know sometimes
unlike myself you know I travel with a
smile but please forgive me guys but the
point is what we love food we love
someone you know looking at someone
maybe smiling instead of looking grumpy
or whatever it may be but what is it
that took away that smile from Burak
what was it brothers and sisters and
indeed when I saw this video of thirsty
number one I was very uh sad to hear
this number two it reminded me of the
Hadith for the prophet Muhammed peace be
upon him which was narrated brothers and
sisters this is what's going on brother
Burak is battling some say it's a tumor
or some kind of a cancer or tumor
whatever it may be inshallah and he is
going through treatment the videos that
you see on my right or left is of him in
hospital undergoing surgery the prophet
Muhammad peace said verily remember the
destroyer of all pleasures which is what
death
death is what it is
I saw a recent video of his where he is
not smiling now some say it was because
of the Turkish earthquake or whatever it
may be but that smile was gone was that
video the same it wasn't and when a
Calamity hits brothers and sisters all
of us when we hear it our faces drop our
hearts sink
why brothers and sisters because we are
too invested in this life so invested
Allah says in the Quran
[Music]
you are too busy with all the fs yeah
and by the way this doesn't work I'm
talking in general
you are too busy worldly affairs with
the worldly Affairs until you visit the
graves and no surely you will know and
know surely you will know
with certainty that in a nutshell that
day you're going to have sharp Vision
2020 is nothing you are going to have
sharp Vision you are going to know that
subhanallah everything Allah's messenger
said is a right in front of my eyes and
guess what everybody on that day is
going to be regretting even the
Believers why because the Believers are
going to say I wish I did more for my
Lord I wish I did more whereas the
disbelievers are going to regret for no
avail I wish we believed it's too late
now brothers and sisters that smile that
is taken from his face shows that the
videos are not the same we sometimes
call it a Calamity and Allah says in the
Quran that we send a smaller Calamity to
divert a bigger Calamity the bigger
Calamity is you losing the Hereafter
there is no bigger Calamity that you can
live than that now I want to ask you
guys a question if you had somebody come
to you and say you are going to die in
one year's time in three months time in
a week's time in four years time
you know that in itself the fact that
you know exactly and maybe that's what
Allah never says tells us when we're
going to die and when judgment is
because that will depress you more but
imagine if someone came and said to you
you know what you're going to die in two
years time
you would say you know what I'm sad that
is going to happen yes but I am happy
that I can prepare for my hair after now
I want to ask you guys a question Allah
does that not with a direct message not
with someone coming to tell not the
angel not wahi not ilham or whatever not
Allah coming and telling you but rather
he does it through calamities
how
and then that is a direct message as if
Allah saying prepare for that day
is that a Calamity or a blessing well
lie be lie that is the biggest blessing
because when you have done the good
deeds and you've repented and then all
of these and not everyone is as lucky
not everyone is lucky to get cancer or a
disease that tells them no no some
people die suddenly suddenly subhanallah
to remind us that not everybody's going
to get these Glad Tidings which we think
is a Calamity and that's what Allah says
you might hate something which is good
for you which is what This calamity that
comes in the form of a disease it's a
direct warning as if Allah is same
your time is running and as if it's a
mercy of Allah
yes he sometimes inspires his servants
that he said that Allah even inspires
our Dua that he wants you know when you
are specific to us Allah is doing that
so you can ask that thing because he
wants to Grant you it it's the same way
when Allah sends a Calamity and makes
you realize times ticking just like our
beautiful brother passed away alibana he
said gifted with cancer indeed it was a
gift he rectified his effects he's got a
charity from him he is inshallah now
probably happy smiling with his Lord
that Calamity that you hate so much will
be the biggest blessing of your life may
Allah
and bring his smile back inshallah till
next time
brothers and sisters may Allah bless you
guys inshallah we are doing some amazing
work at salaam trying to fundraise to
help rivers and warn Muslims learn how
to praise Salah step by step imagine
teaching someone how to recite Surah
Fatiha imagine teaching someone how to
go and record teaching them how to pray
Salah you get the reward of every action
they do and the people and to the people
that they teach the link is in the
description box we have a brother here
who we are teaching how to pray Salah
and in fact many people learn from this
match and come to the Haram and if you
donated for one match and somebody paid
two days Salah here it's equivalent to
one million Salas click the button all
the link and be a part of this amazing
project
[Music]